Manche sehen das Ungewisse als Potenzial für ein Utopia.
Andere sehen darin eher Probleme, die nur darauf warten uns zu begegnen.
Es ist also eine berechtigte Frage:
Warum brauchen wir Wissenschaft?
"Doch lässt sich der Bau einer Mondbasis eigentlich rechtfertigen?"
"Wie sieht die Batterie der Zukunft aus?"
"Der Wendelstein 7-X."
"Jedes Bild eines schwarzen Lochs das du je gesehen hast ist fake!"
"Künstliche Intelligenz dringt in immer mehr Bereiche unseres Lebens ein."
"Was ist das teuerste Objekt, das je von der Menschheit geschaffen wurde?"
"Heute und in den nächsten Videos stelle ich euch die schräge Welt der Quanten vor."
"Jedenfalls lässt mich die Vorstellung, dass ich das unter Umständen noch miterleben kann
voller Vorfreude in die Zukunft blicken."
Herzlich Willkommen zu einem neuen Video auf Doktor Whatson.